nos dicen cuál puede ser la ecuación de
p nos muestra en esta gráfica y nos dan
varias opciones como siempre los invito
a que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta muy bien vamos
a resolverlos juntos podemos ver que
todas las opciones están expresadas como
un polinomio factor izado esta forma es
útil para pensar en las raíces de un
polinomio aquellos valores de x que
hacen que el polinomio sea igual a 0 las
raíces también son evidentes
al ver esta gráfica tenemos una raíz en
x igual a menos 4 tenemos otra raíz en x
igual a menos 1.5 o menos 3 medios y
tenemos otra raíz en x igual a 1 lo que
en realidad tenemos que hacer es buscar
cuáles de estos factores son
consistentes con las raíces que vemos
aquí analicemos raíz x raíz a la
izquierda tenemos una raíz en x igual a
menos 4 y para que este polinomio sea
igual a cero cuando x es igual a menos 4
tiene que tener x 4 común
o esto multiplicado por una constante
como parte del polinomio en las opciones
podemos ver que tenemos varios x 4 pero
tienen diferentes exponentes el primero
tiene un 2 como exponente está elevado
al cuadrado mientras que los demás
tienen un 1 como exponente cuando hemos
hablado de multiplicidad en otros vídeos
dijimos que cuando vemos un cambio de
signo alrededor de una raíz como la que
estamos viendo aquí en x igual a menos 4
quiere decir que vamos a tener un
exponente impar en el factor
correspondiente pero si no vemos un
cambio de signo como lo vemos en esta
otra raíz quiere decir que hay un
exponente para aquí vemos claramente un
cambio de signo por lo que esperamos un
exponente impar y por supuesto que uno
es un número impar y dos no lo es si
tenemos directamente un x más 4 entonces
veremos un cambio de signo en la gráfica
cuando x es igual a menos 4 por lo que
podemos descartar esta opción las
opciones que quedan se siguen viendo
bien por el momento al menos
considerando solamente el factor
4 ahora analicemos la siguiente raíz que
está en x igual a menos tres medios una
forma de pensar en esto es que podemos
tener un factor que luzca como x más
tres medios o esto multiplicado por una
constante cuando vemos las opciones que
quedan no encontramos alguna como x más
tres medios pero si hay algunas con dos
y tres por lo que una forma de pensar en
esto es que si multiplicamos esto con
una constante 2 queda como 2 x 3 que
coincide con lo que tenemos aquí y la
siguiente pregunta es cuál debe ser el
exponente nuevamente tenemos un cambio
de signo alrededor de x igual a menos 3
medios por lo que esperamos un exponente
impar a aquí al ver las opciones nos
damos cuenta de que sólo dos de ellas
tienen exponente 1 que es un número
impar y esta opción tiene un exponente
par por lo que descartamos esta opción
también ahora veamos la última raíz que
es x igual a 1 por lo que esperamos que
x menos 1 oeste
multiplicado por una constante sea uno
de los términos que estamos buscando
aquí lo interesante es que no vemos un
cambio de signo alrededor de x igual a 1
por lo que esperamos un exponente par y
de las opciones que quedan ambas tienen
x menos uno pero la opción c es la única
que tiene este término con exponente
para la opción c se ve bien si vemos la
opción de en donde está el término a la
primera potencia esperaríamos un cambio
de signo alrededor de x igual a 1 esta
sería una situación en donde la curva
sigue hacia abajo más o menos así así
que elegimos la opción c resolvamos otro
ejemplo nuevamente nos preguntan cuál
puede ser la ecuación de p y nos dan
esta gráfica nuevamente pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo vamos a
aplicar la misma idea veamos esta
primera raíz esta raíz está en x igual a
menos 3 por lo que esperamos que algún
múltiplo de x + 3 sea uno de los
factores y también hay un cambio d
signo alrededor de x igual a menos 3 por
lo que esperamos una multiplicidad impar
o un exponente impar en el factor x 3 al
ver las opciones se detiene en exponente
par si tuviéramos x + 3 a la cuarta en
la gráfica no tendríamos un cambio de
signo simplemente la gráfica apenas
tocaría al eje x y regresaría sin
cambiar de signo por lo que descartamos
estas opciones ahora veamos la segunda
raíz aquí en x igualados por lo que
esperaríamos un x menos 2 o un múltiplo
de esto como factor y como no hay un
cambio de signo alrededor de x igualados
la gráfica solamente toca al eje x y
regresa a dónde venía vamos a esperar un
exponente para aquí al ver las opciones
y fijarnos en el factor x menos 2 nos
damos cuenta de que sólo una tiene un
exponente par por lo que elegimos la
opción b y terminamos